you gotta set off on the path of doing
tacking music so really the only thing
that was important in my family was that
you learn how to play music I got a
guitar when I was like three four okay
but yeah I got the computer when I was
like five and for me like in the
beginning it was really all about games
just fun playing from that point I kind
of realized like hey these games are
boring how hard would it be to try to
fix the game yeah and so I started
coding games when I was seven or eight
there's some point it's kind of amazing
that you've been on this trajectory yeah
you know your whole life yeah I've never
had a normal job when I grew up like I
didn't realize how you've made money
starting something yourself were
investing money or life that was just a
totally foreign concept outside of
Silicon Valley Sweden has the highest
per capita number of unicorns which are
startups valued over 1 billion dollars
there's a tension that comes with all
this new money and fame like much of
Scandinavia Sweden operates under a
cultural code of conduct known as Ianto
law it's a philosophy the demands people
not think too highly of themselves
people recognize they do but because
this is like Sweden no one really comes
up except if it's like 10:00 p.m. and
they've had a beer or two cut to 2016
and this way of living finds itself in
conflicts with tech millionaires boozing
it up at clubs and hyping their tight
little apps act knows the situation as
well as anyone
by the time you're 21 I mean you were a
millionaire
especially right because you had sold a
couple businesses and I'm very well for
yourself and then it sounds like you
went through sort of a period where I
don't know if showing off is the right
word but you were living going to clubs
and I was when I look back to it I'm
sort of almost ashamed of myself because
it was like you know it was today I
realized that it was a huge sort of
period of insecurity there's a lot of
fun don't get me wrong but it's it's
like not Who I am and I never know like
it's an outsider if we make too much of
all this but this idea that you don't
want to stand out and yeah I'm Sweden or
Scandinavia and you do stand out when
yeah when you start making billions of
dollars but it is changing I mean if you
walk around in the city now like I see
like Ferraris Lamborghinis like there's
quite a lot of that here which is not
really part of what the fabric of how it
used to be
you